[Musik]
jetzt live aus Köln der Presseclub mit
Jörg Schönenborn
herzlich willkommen schön dass Sie dabei
sind an diesem Sonntagmittag das Robert
habecks Wirtschaftsministerium ein
bisschen wie ein Familienbetrieb geführt
wird war über Monate fast nicht beachtet
in der Öffentlichkeit die beiden
wichtigsten Staatssekretäre sind
verschwägert Bruder und Schwester des
einen Patrick reichen Arbeiten für ein
Institut das wichtige Gutachten für das
Ministerium erstellt so weit so
ungewöhnlich hätte dann nicht dieser
Staatssekretär Patrick reichen besonders
gewarnt sein müssen mit persönlichen
Dingen sensibel umzugehen er will
wochenlang nicht gemerkt haben dass in
einer Findungskommission unter seinem
Vorsitz eine wichtige
geschäftsführerposition unter vielen
Bewerbern ausgerechnet mit seinem
Trauzeugen besetzt wurde nun fordert die
Opposition den Rücktritt des
Staatssekretärs Robert Habeck hält noch
an ihm fest sagt dass sei nur ein Fehler
den man heilen könne aber die Bürde für
den Minister für die Grüne Partei für
die Politik der Grünen wird spürbar
schwerer unser presseclub-thema heute
Mittag Habeck und der Fall reichen
Schmutzkampagne oder Vetternwirtschaft
und ich freue mich richtig auf diese
Runde Albrecht von Lucke ist bei uns
Redakteur der Zeitschrift Blätter für
deutsche und internationale Politik
herzlich willkommen Ulrich Reitz
chefkorrespondent bei Focus Online ich
freue mich auf Barbara junge
Chefredakteurin der Tageszeitung taz und
bei uns ist Julia Ruß vom Bayerischen
Rundfunk landespolitische Reporterin in
München danke für Ihre Rückmeldungen in
den Streams bei Presseclub und
tagesschau.de ich verfolge was sie so
schreiben und Frau Ruß da wird doch
erstaunlich häufig der Rücktritt gleich
des Ministers gefordert das ist ja in
der politischen Debatte noch nicht so
weit was ist ihre Einschätzung was wird
folgen wie weit wird es gehen wie
gefährlich ist das also ich finde es
übertrieben zu fordern das jetzt habe
ich gleich zurücktreten soll also ich
halte für vertretbar zu sagen reichen
sollte jetzt als staatsretär zur ersten
Kosten Räumen na er ist derjenige der ja
was verheimlicht hat oder der nicht
kenntlich gemacht hat dass er seinen
Trauzeugen da mit befördert hat und dass
der ein wichtiges Amt bekommt deswegen
ist wahrscheinlich für Robert habe ich
am besten er lässt ihn entlässt ihn
damit er selber aus dem Schneider ist
wenn die Sache noch sich so weiter dreht
wie es jetzt aktuell aussieht ihre
Einschätzung genauso habe ich kann
bleiben
und nach jetzigem
festhalten materieller Schaden im
Gegensatz zu Maut oder Masken wie es
auch nicht entstanden spannender Punkt
frage ich gleich noch nach Herr von
Lucke was glauben Sie wie endet diese
wie nennt man sie jetzt
trauzeugen-affäre
das ist ganz unklar denn eine Affäre
eine causa wird ja erst dann zur großen
Affäre möglicherweise zum Skandal wenn
sie medial bespielt wird und das was die
Öffentlichkeit daraus macht ist dann das
entscheidende und momentan hat habe ich
schlichtweg noch die Wahl zwischen Pest
und Cholera er hält an reichen fest man
ist eingestandener Weise sein
wichtigster Mann ist der Druck nimmt zu
und insofern wenn er ihn entlässt
verliert er sein wichtigsten Mann noch
ist es meine Sachen nicht so weit hält
an ihm fest bleibt aber dummerweise
dieser Eindruck dass dort eine fatale
Entscheidung getroffen wurde die an
seinem Ministerium kleben bleibt bereits
wir haben gerade in der Tagesschau die
Bilder der einstürzenden Brücke im
Sauerland gesehen dass ein Sinnbild für
die Situation von Harbeck und dem Grünen
wollen ich habe nicht gesehen dass es
Robert habe oder Patrick reichen auf der
Brücke gestanden hätten so aber man
konnte ja eine Statement hören aus Kenia
vom Bundeskanzler also die Geschichte
ist natürlich beim Kabinett Chef
angekommen und der hat sich gewunden und
hat noch eine loyalitätserklärung zu
Robert Habeck abgegeben für Harbeck wäre
es furchtbar wenn er gleichen entlasten
müsste entlassen müsste es ein
wichtigster Mann macht politisch wäre
das schlimm für ihn Robert Habeck selber
hat von einem Meilenstein gesprochen
bei dem Gebäude Energiegesetz es kann
sein dass er mit Recht hat der
Meilenstein besteht dann allerdings
vielleicht darin dass die Grünen den
Kontakt zum Volk verloren haben lassen
Sie uns jetzt mal die Familienpolitik
also die Union macht viele Scherze
Vereinbarkeit von Familie und Beruf und
viele andere Beschreibungen dessen was
da im Wirtschaft und
klimaschutzministerium passiert aber
lassen Sie uns mal trennen das sind ja
sehr verschiedene Dinge ich habe es
eingangs gesagt Frau junge das
Staatssekretäre verschwägert sind
ist selten es kann weiterer Fall bekannt
kann passieren dass dann weitere
Angehörige im Bereich arbeiten der für
das Ministerium auch wirtschaftlich
tätig ist kann passieren all das war
bekannt muss man sagen die
compliance-stelle des Ministeriums hat
sich auch damit befasst ja soweit so
normal und so unbedenklich
also die Fakten waren seit
2021 bekannt wir haben darüber in der
taz längst berichtet es hat sich niemand
aufgeregt zum Ministerium hat es
offengelegt und es ist nicht ideal würde
ich sagen es ist immer besser wenn
verschiedene Ansichten zusammenkommen es
ist aber auch nicht verwunderlich wenn
die einzige Partei die Grünen sind die
Jahrzehnte lang diese Energiewende
vorantreiben dass sie jetzt die Experten
stellen die anderen Parteien Herr Söder
hat sich ja gestern lustig gemacht sie
die und CSU hätten wirklich alle
Möglichkeiten gehabt über Jahre
klimaexpertise aufzubauen was haben sie
gemacht sie haben stattdessen an die
scheuern Verkehrsministerium geschickt
gleiche Einschätzung am Tisch
Widerspruch es gibt zu wenig
Klimaexperten und deswegen sammeln sich
jetzt alle um Robert habe herum in
verschiedenen Think Tanks dann auch in
NGOs die sich zumindest so betiteln und
nichts anderes sind als
Lobby-Organisation
selbstverständlich also wenn es eine
politische Richtung gibt die Stärke ein
Thema verfolgt selbstverständlich sitzen
dann dort mehr Experten und Expertinnen
übrigens war auch schon also die Familie
reichen die Sie gerade erwähnten unter
Habicht Vorgänger anerkannt als Expertin
also wäre
die Schwester greifen aber
ist das wirklich tatsächlich das Problem
dass dort Experten und Expertin
Zusammentreffen der Grünen oder ist es
nicht ein Problem der anderen Parteien
und vielleicht auch für die Klimawende
in Deutschland das geht finde ich sehr
weit aber sie haben völlig Recht vor
junge man muss es soziologisch ein Stück
weit erklären und es ist in der Tat so
dass die Tatsache dass gerade in dem
Milieu der hoch engagierten moralisch
aus dem Umweltbereich kommenden Menschen
die sich dafür seit Jahren stark gemacht
haben einerseits NGOs entstanden sind
diese NGOs mit hohem Einsatz dann
irgendwann inszenzialisiert wurden und
darüber auch so etwas zustande kommt in
der Tat eine sehr kleine Community die
überschaubar ist wie manchmal nicht mal
mehr Trennung von Leben und Beruf das
sind nämlich im Idealismus Menschen die
dann zum Teil sogar eben auch ähnlich
eingehen das sage ich immer salopp
gesagt ist bei der autobi oder bei den
Amigo Verhältnissen die man aus Bayern
kennt manchmal ein bisschen anders wobei
ich auch daran erinnern will das
Verhältnis von Abhängigkeiten und
Zuständigkeiten und Zustellung von Jobs
ist in der amigoaffäre oder in der
maskenpause eine ganz andere gewesen von
den Dimensionen ganz anders auch von der
Selbstbereicherung damit will ich sagen
ist entschuldigt nichts das will ich
deutlich sagen entschuldigt gar nichts
in einem Fall ist es ganz fatal gerade
was Frau junge zurecht sagt das wurde im
Jahre 2021 nach der Wahl sehr durch
exerziert die tatsachs publik gemacht es
wurde dann auch im Ministerium sehr
deutlich klar gemacht wir müssen einen
Riegel vorschieben es muss ganz klar
sein ist darf keine
Jobangebote Ausschreibung geben die
zugunsten des Öko-Instituts gehen in
denen die Schwestern
Bruder das war immer klar und umso
fataler ist natürlich jetzt dieser Kasus
hätte ja gleich in diesen Fehler nicht
gemacht was für mich auch eigentlich
unvorstellbar ist und und fatal hoch
fatal dass er sich selber gewissermaßen
aus dieser Berufungskommission nicht
zurückgezogen hat dann wäre das Ganze
ganz normal gelaufen er hätte nur
gewissermaßen seine Befangenheit
kenntlich machen müssen das ist übrigens
von Robert Habeck nicht gewusst worden
deswegen ist das entscheidende Punkt
genau lassen Sie uns die beiden Dinge
getrennt beachten also ich sag mal die
Verwandtschaftsverhältnisse sind geprüft
worden sind kein Regelverstoß klappt das
sagen sie alle einvernehmlich sie
erklären ein bisschen den Hintergrund
die andere Geschichte ist jetzt die mit
der Ausschreibung also da geht es um
eine deutsche Energieagentur heißt sie
der Bund steuert diese Agentur sehr
stark finanziert sie sehr stark
verschiedene Ministeriums Vertreter
saßen in einer Findungskommission Herr
greifen hatte den Vorsitz es gab 18
Bewerberinnen und Bewerber der
Auswahlprozess führte zum Trauzeugen
Schäfer
mit dem herrg reichen befreundet ist
dieser also berichtet die Arbeit so
berichtet die Bild-Zeitung habe auch
einen gültigen Arbeitsvertrag und
ungefähr drei Wochen nach der
Entscheidung beichtete reichen bei
seinem Minister und der sagte Fehler
kann man heilen Besetzung wird neu
gemacht ist das ein Regelverstoß wusste
fragt ein User auf Twitter herrgreichen
dass er dort gegen Compliance Regeln
verstößt hat er das bewusst getan oder
kann man ihm da Vergesslichkeit
durchgehen Tatsache ist wir reden über
Beamtenrecht wir reden ja nicht über
parlamentarische Staatssekretäre wir
reden auch nicht über externe Berater
sondern wir reden über beamtenrechte
Staatssekretär der beamtete
Staatssekretär ist der oberste Beamte
den Mann haben kann ich habe mal in das
Beamtengesetz geguckt Paragraph 33 heißt
Beamtinnen und Beamte dienen dem ganzen
Volk nicht einer Partei
und sie führen ihr Amt Zitat zum Wohle
der Allgemeinheit das macht klar in
welche Richtung es geht dass der
Staatssekretär
in einer Findungskommission den Vorsitz
hat das geht schon mal per se nicht ich
war viele Jahre lang Aufsichtsrat einer
deutschen Hochschule die Vorstellung
dass eine aus der Führung der
Universität in einer Findungskommission
für einen führenden Beamten irgendwo in
der Universität gesessen habe wäre
völlig unvorstellbar gewesen weil es
eine klassischer Interessenkonflikt ist
und deswegen ist da schon der Fehler
noch mal wir reden über Beamte und die
deutsche Bevölkerung geht davon aus dass
Beamte sich neutral verhalten
das mag eine Fiktion sein bei einzelnen
Leuten aber so ist die Lage und wir
reden hier von Patrick reichen als einem
Beamten und wir reden von den stellen um
die es geht als stellen die an einem
Ministerium im Umfeld dranhängen das
heißt wir reden über das Staatswohl und
deswegen ist das auch der Maßstab junge
selbstverständlich gehört eine
ordentliche Portion Hybris dazu es nicht
vorher zu merken es ist übrigens aus der
Überheblichkeit entsteht aber weil sie
ja auch und die ZuschauerInnen nach
Erklärungen Fragen das war vor der
ganzen Gebäude Energiegesetz das heißt
es war nach diesem Winter diesen
krisenwinder durch den uns tatsächlich
dieses Ministerium Robert Habeck und
Patrick reichen gebracht haben die
konnten vor Kraft nicht mehr laufen
daraus entstehen denke ich solche Fehler
aber Robert habe ich hatte im
Ministerium selbst schon gewarnt in
diesen Krisen wenn er es werden Fehler
passieren wir haben eine zu hohe Taktung
Entscheidungen müssen viel zu schnell
getroffen werden das entschuldigt das
nicht aber es ist ja auch wichtig zu
sehen was eigentlich passiert ist da
waren wir auch noch everybody Starling
Frau Rosa von Luca also für die Grünen
hat jemand diese Woche im
Deutschlandfunk reagiert ja ich sag mal
der Politik aus den Schützengräben kennt
ich meine das
wohlgemerktorisch Jürgen Trittin und der
hat eine ganz klare Meinung wie das zu
bewerten ist
Wirtschaftsministerium wird jetzt
sozusagen in bester Steve Berlin schon
mal hier von Bild und anderen unter
Druck gesetzt der Flores shit es gibt
eine gezielte Kampagne die wird aus
dieser rechten Ecke betrieben sie wird
gefeuert von der CDU CSU und einer
Kampagne begegnet man am besten die man
hier nicht machen
muss Kampagne das ist ja das übliche
Vorgehen dann wenn einem was auf die
Füße fällt dann sagt man einfach
eigentlich ist es nicht so schlimm
gewesen das ist nur der Schmutzkampagne
von Bild oder von Springer und ehrlich
gesagt das finde ich sehr vorhersehbar
und es man kann ja nicht weg Leuten dass
da was passiert ist das nicht nicht
korrekt ist
ja es ist wahr es ist was aber wir
müssen natürlich auch vielleicht da bei
nächster Gelegenheit danach durchaus
darüber reden dass nicht erst seit
diesem Vorfall von Springer Robert
Habeck wie eine Sau durch Dorf getrieben
wird wie eine Sau durchs Dorf getrieben
wird es werden Dinge hochgezogen und man
gewissen mittlerweile auch sollten wir
genau drüber reden Herr töpfner hat ja
klar seine Direktive ausgegeben es ist
mit der FDP zusammen die Ampelkoalition
und die Grünen expliziten damit genau
das verhindert werden muss was Robert
habe Weg macht aber ich will noch mal
zurückkommen wir wollen das ja nicht
dabei belassen nein ich halte ihn
trotzdem für in dem Punkte falsch leitet
weil er den Fehler zu Leuten ist falsch
es ist ein Fehler ich teile aber ihre
Meinung nicht erreichst es ist ja ein
parlamentarischer Staatssekretär weiter
dabei es waren ja zwei Staatssekretäre
bei der Auswahl beteiligt also dass da
nie ein Staatssekretär bei derartigen
Auswahl kriegt
das ist ja beamtete darüber muss man
reden aber trotzdem nicht vorgenommen
Frage beamteter Staatssekretär ein
Auswahlverfahren teilnehmen können das
ist doch nicht der Kase für eigenen
Bereich sind die Grünen
es geht auch gar nicht darum entweder es
war hoch fahrlässig hoch fahrlässig und
er hat es danach ja auch habe ich sagen
müssen oder gewollt das ist die eine
Frage oder es war sogar mit einem
gewissen Willen in dem in der Ahnung
vielleicht muss ich druck machen um
meinen Mann durchzubringen diese beiden
Möglichkeiten gibt es und beide sind
falsch der Fehler ist nicht so Leute und
deswegen ist der Satz von habe ich auch
nicht richtig ja man kann den Fehler
rechtlich heilen das Verfahren wird neu
ausgeschrieben es kostet eine Stange
Geld und ich garantiere Ihnen die
Bild-Zeitung fängt schon an wir haben
jetzt eine große Debatte um die Frage
wie der Schäfer abgefunden wird
möglicherweise mit einer Menge Geld das
ist die freuen sich das ist die nächste
Kampagne die betrieben wird aber der
zweite Punkt ist es wird dadurch der
politische Fehler nicht geheilt und das
ist so dramatisch da hat tritt ihn
leider recht das Ministerium steht in
einem Feuer die noch kein Ministerium
zuvor weil es um eine ganz große Frage
geht es so etwas und gelingt ist ein
Gewissen Abschied zu nehmen von der
fossilistischen Moderne und das da
Interessen im Spiel sind die voll
dagegenhalten ist doch evident eine
Frage will ich kurz auch greifen aus
unseren Chats das ist nämlich wer für
den Schaden haftet sie haben es gesagt
so ein Auswahlverfahren kostet Geld
mindestens Arbeitszeit hoch bezahlter
Leute die Bild-Zeitung meldet es gebe
sogar einen gültigen Arbeitsvertrag für
den Trauzeugen der möglicherweise
abgefunden werden müsse aber selbst wenn
das nicht ist ist ja auch ein
wirtschaftlicher Schaden entstanden muss
Herr reichen als tatssekretär privat
dafür bezahlen was er an Schaden
ausgelöst hat durch seinen Fehler oder
haftet bei einem Beamten der Bund weiß
das jemand das ist kein ähm es gibt
keinen staatshaftungsrecht dafür also es
ist ganz einfach
für wenn solche Fehler passieren und der
ist ja ist ja ein eingestandener Fehler
deswegen ist es auch keine Kampagne
nicht an der Stelle und deswegen haftet
deswegen haftet ähm Herr reichen
überhaupt nicht persönlich genauso wie
Bundeskanzler oder Bundesminister nicht
für Dinge haften wo sich fünf Jahre
später rausstellt ist man Schuss in den
Ofen sondern das halt ganz einfach die
Allgemeinheit und es ist über auch
üblich
das kenne ich aus meinen
findungskommissionen es ist völlig
üblich dass wenn Sie jemanden in
erfindungskommission herausgefunden
haben dass sie den Vertrag geben dass er
den Vertrag unterzeichnet und so weiter
das ist völlig üblich jetzt ist in
diesem Verfahren ein von Habeck
eingestandener compliance-fehler
passiert die Wahrheit ist die
allgemeinheithaft okay
ins Verhältnis setzt was bei der
maskenaffäre und bei der mautgebung nein
das sind Millionen über die wir da
sprechen aber hier sprechen wir nicht
über Millionen nein ich will auch was
anderes raus der Schaden liegt doch so
ganz anders der Schaden liegt bei
Michael Schäfer der diese Stelle nicht
bekommen wird der Schaden liegt auf
jeden Fall bei den Grünen
selbstverständlich
selbst auch mal fragen müssen ob das mit
rechten Dingen sollen er erinnert sich
er erinnert sich erinnert sich ja
wahrscheinlich auch an die Trauung der
beigebracht
Schaden es ist nicht gut wie es gelaufen
ist ich glaube da sind für uns einig
lassen Sie uns über Schaden sprechen
diese Woche gab es einen ARD
deutschland-trend unter anderem wie
jeden Monat mit der Befragung der
persönlichen Werte von Robert Habeck wir
alle wissen er war der Liebling der
deutschen Wahlbevölkerung er hat die
Grünen durch seine Politik kräftig nach
oben gezogen das ist die Entwicklung
seiner persönlichen beliebtheitskurve
nee das ist sie nicht ähm haben wir die
ja genau wer wechseln und haben jetzt
die Entwicklung der Werte von Robert
Habeck er war über Monate der
beliebteste Minister im Kabinett
manchmal gleich auf mit Frau beerbock
und jetzt sehen wir Absturz auf 30
Prozent er liegt jetzt nicht nur hinter
Kanzler Scholz sondern in einer
Größenordnung mit Christian Lindner das
ist der Schaden für Robert Habeck
persönlich von dem wir nicht sagen
können hat er nun mit der
heizungspolitik zu tun hat er mit
Patrick reichen zu tun und jetzt gerne
noch mal die andere Grafik wir haben in
der Wahlforschung eine ganz interessante
Frage im Hintergrund welches Potenzial
hat eine Partei nicht nur das was man
bei der Wahl wirklich bekommt sondern
die Frage ist könnten Sie sich eventuell
vorstellen nicht diese Partei sondern
auch die Union auch die SPD auch die
Grünen zu wählen und da war es so dass
vor der letzten Bundestagswahl die
Grünen mit
50%, das höchste Potenzial hatten also
die Hälfte der Menschen konnte sich
vorstellen Grün zu wählen das war
Augenhöhe mit Union und SPD und Sie
sehen es an der grafikunion ein bisschen
zu gewonnen SPD ein bisschen zu gewonnen
seit dem Frühjahr
ein paar Jahren und die Grünen stürzen
ab wieder auf das Niveau der FDP also
sie waren fast Volkspartei und sind
jetzt wieder auf dem Niveau einer Partei
die man auch als Klientelpartei
bezeichnet also ich gebe Ihnen noch mal
das Wort Frau sie haben ja angefangen
den Schaden auszuführen für Robert
Habeck für die Grünen für die
Klimapolitik
vieles davon ist noch nicht reichen nee
vieles davon ist noch nicht reichen auf
jeden Fall es ist tatsächlich so es
wurde zwar immer gesagt Robert Habeck
ist kanzlerfähig aber zumindest die
letzten Monate in dieser Krisenzeit
etwas also wirklich gestern nicht
realistisches heute nicht realistisch
und wahrscheinlich auch 25 nicht
realistisch ähm das sind grünes
Kanzleramt oder ein grüner Kanzler
Robert Harbeck am Ende der Wahl steht
ähm es sei denn es passiert
die Zeit ist im Moment nicht besonders
einfach gerade für einen
Wirtschaftsminister der auch
gleichzeitig klimaminister ist ohnehin
also ist die richtige Kombination aber
eine schwierige Kombination das kann auf
jeden Fall sagen bitte ich dachte sie
hätten Punkt gemacht ich habe Punkt
gemacht auf das ist jetzt dann ja was
man ja an den Umfragen jetzt sieht oder
an den Veränderungen zu zwei Jahre vor
zwei Jahren ist das die Grünen enorm
einen Glaubwürdigkeit verloren haben
weil sie inszenieren sich ja immer als
die Partei bei denen es keinen
Korruption gibt kann Filz und das gibt
es ja sowieso nur vor allem bei den
wirtschaftsnahen Parteien und jetzt
kommt raus die sind ja auch nicht
unbedingt besser also auch sie haben
ihre Netzwerke und ganz viele
lobby-organisationen um sich herum im
vorpolitischen Raum man tut es immer als
wäre es nur endlich aus und Think Tanks
betitelt die so schön aber letztendlich
sind sie eben auch einfach nur
lobby-organisationen und mittlerweile
schon die Leute das auch zu merken dass
da viele Staatssekretäre dann auch aus
diesem Sumpf kommen und es nicht
unbedingt so viel Unterschied zu anderen
Parteien
was der Begriff Lobby eigentlich sagt
und sehr deutlich zu sagen also
eine schlechte besteht aus
Automobilindustrie
sagen das war jetzt das war jetzt ein
Moment wo niemand was verstanden hat
weil sie parallel geredet haben deshalb
noch mal Frau Ruß mit ihrem Einwurf dann
Herrn
ist teilweise
die es gibt eine gute Lobby eine
schlechte Lobby die schlechte Lob
besteht eben aus diesen ganzen fossilen
Energien und alle die sich dafür stark
machen und die gute Lobby wird ja nicht
mal als Lobby betitelt sondern eben nur
als NGOs als Denkfabriken und eben als
Institute sowie des Ökoinstitut eben
auch sich so
wissenschaftlich gibt und natürlich dort
auch Wissenschaftler beschäftigt sind
aber sie trotzdem interessenvertreten
und das ist den Leuten mittlerweile auch
klar geworden dass es nicht ganz so
neutral abläuft wie man immer tut sich
jetzt zunächst mal fragen wessen
Interessen wirklich gemeint sind und da
wird man leider und das ist ja
eigentlich auch das tale
grün und das Abstoßen von Robert habe
ich
das Problem besteht genau darin und das
ist das eigentlich die Dilemma das habe
ich deshalb abstürzt weil er den
Menschen etwas zumutet eine klassische
Lobby spielt ihren eigenen Leuten
permanent etwas zu das ist der
Lobbyismus Begriff deswegen war nicht
auch ein bisschen davor ja die Grünen
ich teile das was sie sagten ja schön
Bonn die wertig sind so dass ich glaube
und ich würde noch grundsätzlich stimme
da vor junge durchaus bei ich habe große
Zweifel daran dass sie die Kanzlerschaft
noch mal ernsthaft Anteilen können weil
ich auch nicht glaube das war wesentlich
bessere Chancen hätte aber das
eigentliche Problem von Robert habe ich
besteht genau darin dass er den Menschen
erstmalig und das ist einzigartig klar
gemacht hat leider haben sie vielleicht
nicht gleich von Anfang alle drei
gemacht dass diese soziale ökologische
Transformation den gegenwärtig lebenden
enorm etwas kosten wird und das macht
man nicht als Lobby-Organisation wie die
klassische können Sie auch die Masken im
Namen von Herrn Sauter und anderen die
Amigo wo man übrigens in Bayern immer so
schön sagte das ist ein Hund wenn er uns
noch zugeschustert hat hat
Söder ist auch ein Kandidat der macht
ein gewisser Weise im Wahlkampf jetzt
Lobbyarbeit für bayerischen Wahlkampf
und damit Lobbyarbeit für das Land
Bayern gegen den Bund das genau macht
diese grüne Truppe nicht und das ist der
eigentliche fatale Haken das genau und
das macht es so fatal jetzt der Eindruck
entsteht das werfe ich ja gleichen auf
massiv vor dass der Eindruck entstehen
und auch die dumme die auch die
Ernennung von Kellner als Stadt ganz
ganz blöd könnte das im Detail erklären
weil es mit den ganz fatalen links
rechts Koordination bei den Benennung
der Posten zustande kam das jetzt dieser
Eindruck entsteht den sie jetzt stark
machen das hier auch sich eben eine
Familie Stark positioniert hat ist so
fatal weil es das eigentlicher
Hauptanliegen konterkariert das
erstmalig und das ist eine riesiger Mut
den ja auch dieses habe ich Ministerium
auch wenn das erstmalig klar gesagt wird
gegen die Gegenwart Interessen es wird
uns etwas kosten und leider ich mache
aber auch da den Grünen einen anderen
Vorwurf wäre das am Anfang mal gesagt
wurden denn es war von Anfang an klar
hätte man sich nicht in das Eier mit der
FDP gegeben und gesagt wir lieben uns in
selfies doch alle und es wird das war
nämlich der anfangs angegangen dieser
wir können diese Ampelkoalition wo alle
sagten das läuft technologisch gemacht
ist der Punkt aber dass das jetzt auf
die Grünen hereinbricht ist das ist der
Kardinal das Kardinalproblem und da
werden sie sich auch nicht erholen weil
das merken die Leute plötzlich und ich
sehe nicht dass diese Bereitschaft zu
verzichten und etwas sich Kosten also
das ist glaube ich das riesen Problem
für Wirtschaftsverbände für
Wirtschaftsinteressen so was ganz
anderes als allgemein wofür lobbyieren
die noch mal für den Erhalt der
Lebensgrundlagen der Menschheit ich
finde das nicht so schwierig und ich
finde dass wir auch darüber sprechen
müssen anstatt da jetzt dieses Monstrum
von lobbit rüber zu stülpen aber warum
macht der Unterschied warum ist die eine
Seite immer so viel ja warum ist sie so
viel besser wird werden vertreten das
ist doch die entscheidende Frage wird
ein partialinteresse vertreten das auch
noch wirtschaftlich hinterlegt ist oder
wird ein allgemeines Interesse vertreten
das nicht keine einzigen
wirtschaftlichen Vorteile hat immer ins
Öko-Institut hat wenig er Aufträge jetzt
ähm seit habe ich das und nicht mehr
vorher Reiz dran ist ich will einfach
ich finde diesen Austausch
hochinteressant weil er ja im Kern um
die Frage geht wer bewertet das Anliegen
das hinterlobbyarbeit steckt also wer
hat die Autorität zu sagen es gibt ein
gutes und es gibt ein schlechtes
Anliegen das ist ja möglich aber
irgendjemand muss es ja bewerten heraus
ich gehe noch mal einen Schritt zurück
okay das ist mir zu weit oben
was da passiert ist und da habe ich und
reichen ist einfach sau schlechtes
Handwerk wenn ich den Leuten in ihrer
Häuser eingreife und den Mietern in
ihrem mieten eingreifen dann muss ich
das so machen machen dass sie es
verstehen vielleicht kriege ich sie
sogar dazu dass sie Spaß dran haben an
dieser Transformation aber von
staatswegen ein Befehl zu erteilen oder
wie jetzt im Energiewirtschaftsgesetz
die Zahl der ähm der der Wärmepumpen
genau fest schreiben zu wollen ist genau
das Falsche und das Gegenteil von
Selbstbestimmung deswegen haben die
Menschen das Gefühl der Macht ihn ein
Staat
intransparent
Vorschriften und sie haben keine
Möglichkeit mehr einzugreifen und das
ist der politische aus meiner Sicht der
politische Kern der Affäre und der
Fehler insgesamt die Zeit hat
geschrieben deswegen ist es auch keine
Kampagne Springer Verlags die schönsten
Zitate finden Sie in den Blättern des
Holz bringt Verlages der
Wirtschaftswoche der Zeit oder der tazdi
das Thema überhaupt aufgebracht hat so
das mit dem Familienbetrieb die
Vetternwirtschaft schreibt die Zeit und
so weiter der Fehler ist eben dass man
nicht sagt wir haben einen die
Entwicklung eines co2-preises das wird
alles teurer das hat einen Preis und
jeder einzelne Bürger muss das bezahlen
sondern dass man sagt ab nächstes Jahr
ja von heute an den 7 Monaten muss ich
wenn der Heizung kaputt geht so ein Ding
einbauen und wir haben keine Handwerker
wir haben die Netze nicht richtig
verlegt deswegen hat jetzt wohnovia
gesagt wir können keine Wärmepumpen
einbauen das größte deutsche
mietunternehmen das ist alles ganz
einfach schlechtes Handwerk
verantwortlich Patrick reichen derselbe
der schon die gasumlage vor die Wand
gesetzt hat ganz einfach also einfach
ist es nicht weil ich gebe ihn durchaus
recht es ist insofern fatal als die
soziale Begleitung dieses Gesetzes von
Anfang an nicht gestimmt hat es ist aber
auch bekannt nicht dieses Gesetz
möglicherweise im völlig unvollendet
Entwurf durchgestochen wurde muss man
bei der Gelegenheit dazu sagen und das
ein anderes Kardinalproblem besteht das
ja die Grünen und auch hier habe ich
nicht von Anfang an nur gegen eine
normale Opposition Politik machen muss
sondern faktisch gegen zwei
Oppositionsparteien eine dezidiert
nämlich die FDP und eine Schweigen
nämlich die SPD in der eigenen Regierung
wenn die zitiert direkt von der FDP
gegen ein Gesetz gekontert wird und
nicht gemeinsam ein konstruktiver
Versuch gemacht wird es sozial
abzuwählen zu sagen es sind Schwächen
oder möglicherweise im Vorgang bereits
versuchte ein konsistentes Gesetz zu
machen dann wird natürlich die Grüne
Partei immer wieder gegen die Wand von
Luke ich würde sagen
einmal versuchen noch mal
zusammenzufassen was ich jetzt so aus
dieser letzten Runde wahrgenommen habe
also auf der einen Seite das ist sehr
stark ihre Position aber auch von Frau
junge sie haben gesagt Herr von Lücke
Harbeck mutet den Leuten etwas zu es ist
riesiger Mut das wird unsere Generation
viel kosten was jetzt nötig ist und
dabei sind Fehler passiert aber es ist
ein zentrales existenzielles Anliegen
Herr bereit sagt es sind so viele Fehler
passiert dass man sich die Frage stellen
muss was machen die eigentlich für eine
Politik und was ist das für ein Handwerk
und richtig ist ja das Staatssekretär
reichen für die Gesetzentwürfe die zur
Kampagne gemacht wurden oder nicht
erfolgreich waren jedenfalls
verantwortlich war wenn ich mich jetzt
in die Perspektive der Grünen und Herrn
Harbeck versetze dann musste auch die
Frage sein wie wäre ich von jetzt ab am
erfolgreichsten mit meinem Anliegen bei
Boris Pistorius bitte wir haben eine
zurückgetretene Verteidigungsministerin
weil kein Mensch verstanden hat was die
da macht so und jetzt haben wir ein
Verteidigungsminister und deswegen ist
der Vergleich zu diesem Gebäude gesetzt
treffen weil der greift der Gebäude
Entwurf greift tief ins Leben der
Menschen ein
die Bundesregierung mit der Zeitenwende
mit der militärischen Zeitenwende tut es
auch alte Gewissheiten werden auf den
Kopf gestellt es wird dramatisch viel
Geld ausgegeben schauen sich die
Kommunikation von Boris Pistorius an die
Beliebtheitswerte sind an der Spitze der
verschweigt nix der hat auch kein fetter
Problem
sondern der macht gerade aus Politik und
sagt es wird teuer und jeder Einzelne
muss es bezahlen ich kann von ein paar
Tage darauf Partei die angetreten ist
als antipartei schon vor 40 Jahren kann
ich doch erwarten dass sie nicht ihr
Erbe verrät sondern genauso transparent
und moralisch sauber vorgeht und das
machen sie hier eben nicht und das ist
der Fehler
jetzt aus der Energiewende Politik das
klimaschutzministeriums ich würde mir
wünschen die nicht durch Verbote
stattfindet weil das genau ist ja das
was die Menschen aufregt dass man
Energie Wärmepumpen verordnet dass man
auch den Verbrennermotor abschafft bis
2035 wurde auch beschlossen auf die
EU-Ebene und man hat ja keine gescheiten
Alternativen man hat keine E-Autos wo es
überall schon die Infrastruktur gibt wo
das die billig sind die die man sich
leisten kann genauso bei inne bei den
Wärmepumpen ja auch da gibt's auch nicht
genug es gibt nicht genug Handwerker die
die Dinge einbauen können nicht genug
die überhaupt wissen wie wie das wie das
genau leichter ist und dann zu sagen ab
nächsten Jahr bauen wir diese
Wärmepumpen überall ein in neuen ähm
diese ja in Häusern das macht doch
keinen Sinn wir sind ja sofort folgen
ich will nur mal Klammer wir sind ja in
einer Situation wo der Gesetzentwurf
über das gasheizungsverbot zwar vom
Kabinett verabschiedet wurde die FDP
aber offen gehalten hat ob Sie zustimmt
das war jetzt vor dem Skandal mit Herrn
reichen das heißt wir wissen gar nicht
ob und in welcher Form dieses
das kommt und aus der Situation heraus
die Frage was kommt jetzt auf uns zu wer
triumphiert am Ende das tatsächlich das
Fatale an dieser Situation dass jetzt
hat die gegen dieses Gebäude
Energiegesetz sind gegen das
heizungsgesetz jetzt gegen reichen
schießen wunderbare Angriffsfläche
geboten aber das Problem ist ja
tatsächlich dass die Grünen jetzt ich
sag das vorher auch so geschwächt sind
die gehen im Büßerhemd also bis auf
jugendrettin macht ja niemanden den Mund
auf man hört keinen
man hört keine ricarda-langen und mit
nur es sagt niemand etwas die Grünen
dachten ja zumindest immer dass sie
anders sind haben jetzt kapiert sind
auch nicht wirklich anders das schwächt
sie enorm gute schwächt natürlich auch
das Gesetz selbst wenn der Bundeskanzler
jetzt noch versichert es wird bis auf
kleine Änderungen dieses Gesetz so
durchgehen die Grünen können es nicht
mehr mit der gleichen Energie vertreten
und das Problem den Freiheitsgedanken in
allen nähern aber das Problem ist ja
eher die Zeit wir müssen das ja zügig
machen jetzt ist der gleichen so an
angeschossen dass er selbst auch nicht
mehr das mit der gleichen vehements
durchziehen kann und außer ihm kann es
ganz offensichtlich keiner also überall
wo man sich erkundigt unisono ähm erster
unersetzbar die anderen Prominenten
gründen
weil sie davon ausgehen dass sie eine
moralische Partei sind dass eine andere
Partei sind alles was ich höre im
Ministerium außerhalb des Ministeriums
innerpartei ist Scham einfach Scham das
ist ja sogar mehr sie gestehen ja sogar
ein dass ein Fehler gemacht wurde also
Jürgen tritt ziemlich alleine
ja es ist ja nun sie können ja an der
fatalen Situation auch erstmal nicht so
leicht vorbei sie machen aber folgendes
und das finde ich auch richtig sie sagen
zuerst einmal der Fehler ist gemacht
worden ganz klar außer Trittin der
sofort von der Kampagne spricht was ich
auch nicht für flugfälle bei der Fehler
ist mit reichen gemacht worden aber
jetzt geht es natürlich darum auch und
das machen sie schon wieder die
Offensive zu kommen und gerade
beispielsweise auch Robert habe ich ganz
konkret zu sagen spielt in beide
gewissermaßen zurück was wäre denn die
Alternative ernst nehmen dass diese
Regierung klar gesagt hat übrigens eine
Spitze der Bundeskanzler wir sind eine
Klima Koalition wir wollen eine
Klimapolitik machen dann sagen Sie doch
mal wie die alternativ mal zum Worte
wäre die eine alternativ besteht darin
erheblich Steuern zu erhöhen das ist das
was Robert habe
vorgeschlagen hat eine Steuererhebung
zum Zwecke der großen Umrüstung der
Transformation auf dem Wege der auch
durchaus erheblichen Belastung der
besser situierten deshalb habe ich
deutlich ist abgeprallt ist klar
abgeprallt dass die erste Option die
zweite Option das muss man leider sehr
deutlich sagen sie kommen immer mit
marktförmigen Möglichkeiten wir haben
gegenwärtig einen Energie CO2-Preis ich
weiß es nicht genau 23 irgendwas in dem
Bereich die Schweden haben ein CO2-Preis
von über 100 € pro Tonne die haben ihre
Wärmepumpen vor 20 Jahren angefangen
einzubauen und zu ersetzen die Grünen
leiden darunter das über 20 Jahre keine
ökonomisch verträgliche Politik von
einer davor sehr viel eigentlich sich
marktwirtschaftlicher gerierenden Partei
konnten Frau Merkel und seitwärme Spitze
nie durchgeführt wurde deswegen haben
sie das große Problem dass der sanfte
weg und den hätte ich bei für weit
besser mit dem Zwang des Marktes zu
operieren zu sagen wir lassen die
Produkte die ökologische Wahrheit sagen
wir legen einen CO2 Preis drauf dass
dieser Weg gar nicht gangbar wäre weil
dann müsste man sofort auf 100 CO2 100 €
pro 24 dann hätten wir auf dem Weise
auch eine praktische Verbot Option das
heißt sie sind und ich will ja gar nicht
glauben
ja wissen Sie was mich von ihnen
unterscheidet ich will nicht Politiker
sein
ja das ist unser Job nicht nur doch der
entscheidende Punkt ist wir haben im
Moment ein Gesetz auf dem Tisch legen
das dazu führt dass die Leute reinweise
Gasheizung neu einbauen das ist also ein
GAU der passiert ist aufgrund eines
Gesetzes ich verlange nur ich habe
nichts dagegen ich bin der Meinung wer
grünen Welt der sieht ja jetzt was er
kriegt okay alles in Ordnung würde ich
niemals kritisieren ich kritisiere nur
handwerkliche Sauberkeit ich kritisiere
Anspruch und Wirklichkeit diese Dinge
und Tatsache ist wir haben ein Gesetz
das führt zu Gegenteil dessen was die
Absicht war die Leute bauen Gasheizungen
ein und ich habe niemanden der eine
Bevölkerung mitgeht wissen Sie bei der
Klimawende habe ich gelernt nicht meine
Erfindung Erfindung der Grünen
Klimawende wird nur gelingen wenn die
Bevölkerung Lust drauf hat und wenn sie
es gut findet und glauben Sie im Ernst
dass bei diesem Weg der jetzt gemacht
worden ist irgendjemand draußen in der
Welt sagt das machen wir auch so
also erstens sind andere Länder schon
viel weiter als Deutschland also
insofern irgendwer in der Welt ist schon
bereit diesen Weg zu gehen da sind wir
Deutschen offensichtlich ein bisschen
Störer
das zweite ist aber auch tatsächlich wie
erwähnen hier nie dass da noch aus dem
über den Verteidigungsminister ist da
irgendwo noch einen Krieg tobt und dass
wir diese gasmangel Lage hatten und das
gleichzeitig die Energiekrise und die
Energiewende
bewältigt werden muss das wird nicht so
glatt ablaufen wie am grünen Tisch es
ist absolut wahr und es ist es gibt
keine Rechtfertigung für schlechtes
handwerklich ich freue mich meine Herren
meine Damen ich freue mich über die
kontroverse Debatte die ich so deutlich
gar nicht erwartet hätte weil der
Ausgangspunkt ja kurios ist die
Bewerbungssituation des Trauzeugen aber
ich finde ihre Diskussion macht deutlich
es gibt eine unstreitige Notwendigkeit
dem klim Handel zu begegnen ich glaube
die Breite der deutschen Bevölkerung
durch fast alle Parteien hindurch auch
die Politik akzeptiert das das ist gar
nicht die Diskussion ob der Klimaschutz
brauchen oder nicht wir haben aber eine
große Kontroverse darüber wie er
umgesetzt wird und wir erleben gerade
dass diese sag mal Radikalisierung der
Positionen dazu führt dass
möglicherweise wenig bis gar nichts
umgesetzt wird das ist nicht vorangeht
deshalb zum Schluss mein stimmt nicht
dran aber ich kann jetzt ja durchsetzen
die Frage ist mit welchen Änderungen
aber es ist unstreitig dass das durch
geht ja ich ja ich fange mit Frau an ähm
wie ist die Perspektive für Klimaschutz
für den Rest der Regierungszeit
angesichts dieser Grabenkämpfe die wir
gerade haben das ist alles nicht so
einfach ist wie die Grünen sich das
vorstellen sie sind ja auch in der
Koalition mit drei anderen Partnern die
FDP stellt sich ja gewissermaßen bei
vielen Dingen einfach quer und deswegen
wird man eben nach der Zeit in der
Regierung auch merken dass viele Dinge
nicht so weit gekommen sind wie sie sich
gerne wünschen und dann entzaubern sie
sich dadurch natürlich also merkt ja
auch jetzt schon dass auf der Straße
viele klimaschutzschützer sind die
letzte Generation zum Beispiel die mit
den Grünen auch nicht mehr so viel
anfangen können weil die viel zusammen
sanft geworden sind und ich halte sie
jetzt auch in den Methoden diese
einsetzen auch die Grünen selbst für
einfach diese Verbotspolitik die wird
bei den Menschen einfach nicht fruchten
die werden das nicht verstehen und es
wird die Leute nur noch viel mehr
aufregen einerseits die Aktivisten die
immer auf der Straße hat andererseits
die Grünen die das mit ähm mit Gesetzen
durchfechten wollen die einfach zu weit
gehen und zu schnell durchgesetzt werden
sollen also wenn sie richtig verstehe
sie beobachten diese Radikalisierung und
sagen das führt am Ende zu weniger
Fortschritt und weniger gibt
Freiwilligkeit einfach bei den Menschen
selbst ja würde ich unterschreiben ich
guck mal kurz auf den Zeitplan Mittwoch
haben wir Wirtschaftsausschuss Herr
reichen sagt da aus dann danach
entscheidet sich die Frage ist die
Opposition einverstanden nicht nur die
Union sondern auch die Linke die den
Rücktritt gefordert hast danach die
Frage entschieden wahrscheinlich in der
Union gibt es ein Untersuchungsausschuss
zu dem Thema ja oder nein also deswegen
das Thema Rücktritt und so weiter steht
jetzt nicht so im Raum sondern wie geht
es parlamentarisch weiter dann wird sich
der Bundeskanzler einfinden müssen und
der Bundesfinanzminister der Herr der
Kassen weil ja die Dinge die Herr Habeck
auf den Tisch liegt jetzt 25 bis 30
Milliarden mehr die müssen bezahlt
werden die FDP sagt nein das heißt wir
werden bis zur Sommerpause werden wir
erleben bleibt die Koalition stabil wie
verhält sich der Chef der Koalition der
Kanzler kann der den Laden noch
zusammenhalten das passiert in der
Politik oben drüber vor sich entscheidet
was sozusagen mit diesem Gesetzentwurf
passiert danke für die Prognose von
locker ja ich glaube vor allem eines äh
sie sagten so schön Herr reizt das Wort
Lust es muss Lust machen ja sie haben
völlig recht wenn man es außenpolitisch
denken bzw als als Exportprodukt das war
der Gedanke Deutschland muss etwas vor
Exerzieren was möglicherweise dann die
Welt nachempfinden kann oder vielleicht
sogar ohne dass ich jetzt sofort
kassieren des deutschen Besen soll die
Welt gehen kommt ja sofort wieder aus
der Kampagnenseite aber der Gedanke
etwas attraktiv zu machen dass dann auch
tauglich ist in als Exportmodell zu
ziehen das hat aber leider auf der
innenpolitischen Seite nicht nur mit
Lust zu tun wir werden uns ehrlich
machen müssen wir werden diese
ökologische Transformation nicht durch
völlig gleich bleibenden Spaß
bewerkstelligen und das war der
kardinien
das Volk haben
ja leider und das ist leider das Problem
dieser ganzen Koalition vor allem eine
FDP die von Anfang an gesagt hatten
jetzt wir machen ja nicht mit übrigens
von massiven Lobbys er verlockend aber
in dieser dieser druckschloss dass das
von reichen und habe ich schlecht
gemacht oder handwerklich bin ich dabei
aber wir müssen von der Illusion
verabschieden dass es uns nicht in der
Gegenwart etwas kostet das ist naiv
sonst werden wir die Zukunft Generation
nicht bewahren ich hatte sogar ein
bisschen nach einer Prognose gefragt das
Problem ist dass ich die Grünen in ihre
Einschätzung getäuscht haben was Olaf
Scholz mit Klima Kanzler meint wir
dachten der spricht vom aber Olaf Scholz
ist nur so weit dabei wie es um
technischen Fortschritt geht sozial
abgefedert da ist kein kein Lizenz aber
die Vorstellung sind sehr
unterschiedlich die FDP ist da
vielleicht sogar das kleinere Problem
jetzt vielen herzlichen Dank die Affäre
Grenchen ein Beispiel dafür wie
politisch das persönliche werden kann
wir sprechen über die Besetzung einer
gut dotierten aber einer Führungsstelle
und haben die Frage ob die
energiewendepolitik dadurch ins Stocken
gerät sich verändert bedanke mich sehr
herzlich hier in der ARD jetzt das
europamagazin unter anderem mit einem
Schwerpunkt zu den steigenden
Flüchtlingszahlen in Europa bleiben sie
aber auch gerne dabei Presseclub
nachgefragt im Netz im Radio und bei
Phoenix schön dass Sie dabei waren
tschüss und lassen sich gut gehen
und willkommen zurück Presseclub
nachgefragt im Netz auf den Kanälen von
Tagesschau und Presseclub bei WDR 5 im
Radio und bei Phoenix im Fernsehen und
in Warburg in ja Ostwestfalen ist das
bei Anke Fabian hallo Frau Fabian sie
sind dran hallo
bitte sie haben das Wort und auch guten
Tag an die Runde ich bin sehr der
Meinung dass wir es hier nicht mit einer
Kleinigkeit zu tun haben es ist greift
sehr viel größer und weiter ich habe im
Hinterkopf zum Beispiel die beiden
Rücktritte Köhler Wulff das waren im
Verhältnis kleinere geschehen die
passiert sind
für mich ist es auch anders wie die
junge Frau von der tats gesagt hat mir
reicht es einfach nicht aus Scham und
Fehler einzugestehen und keine
Millionenschäden vorläufig verursacht zu
haben sondern ich denke schon dass es
Konsequenzen anders und meine Frage an
den Herrn Reiz ist welche Konsequenzen
kann und wird und sollte es wirklich für
Herrn reichen auf jeden Fall aber auch
für Herrn
danke schön vor Fabian der ich bin jetzt
aus dem Stand nicht in der Lage das zu
vergleichen mit den Rücktritten von
Köhler und Wolf sehen Sie es mir nach
wir haben das Beamtenrecht ich habe eben
daraus zitiert Paragraph 33 gucken sie
gucken sie noch mal nach das sind auch
alles ja allgemein zugängliche Quellen
ich glaube aber diese Frage wird
politisch entschieden die Kollegin von
der Tatsache darauf hingewiesen Frau
junge dass im Moment bemerkenswert ist
dass
niemand aus der Führungsriege sich an
die Seite von den Haarwerk stellt das
ist bemerkenswert deswegen solche Sachen
also wenn sie gucken in die Geschichte
der Rücktritte dann hängt das sehr davon
ab verliert einer die Unterstützung
seiner eigenen Truppe und im Moment ist
es eben so ähm die Truppe macht aus die
Grünen die Grünen haben sich verkrochen
einer lena bärburg ist nicht am
Spielfeld um in Norwegen ist nicht auf
dem Spielfeld der parteivorsitzen ne der
Kanzler gibt von der Seitenlinie aus
Ratschläge die aber deutlich machen dass
er kritisiert was dabei passiert ist
Ihre Frage ist richtig und kommt dann
noch zu früh weil es entscheidet sich
erst im politischen Prozess vielen
herzlichen Dank Gruß nach Warburg und
wir springen nach Berlin zur Astrid
Peters guten Tag frau Peters bitte sie
haben das Wort
wunderschönen guten Tag also erstens
wundere ich mich dass sie sich derart
von der Bild-Zeitung aufrufen lassen und
sich und über ein Thema reden was ich
also schon merkwürdig finde weil
Trauzeuge ist ja gar kein
Verwandtschaftsgrad und dass ich
Experten untereinander befreunden das
finde ich völlig normal und ich möchte
gerne regiert werden von Experten und
nicht von Politikern die sich nicht mehr
erinnern oder die ihr Fähnchen ständig
verändern ich danke übrigens der Frau
Reiz dass sie
ein gewisses
eine eine eine gewisse Logik in diese
Umwelt Angelegenheit gebracht haben denn
worum geht es denn eigentlich es geht
doch darum dass wir noch atmen können
dass wir noch Wasser trinken können und
dass wir überhaupt noch leben können
zumindestens unsere Nachfahren ich
möchte haben reicht
möchte ich gerne fragen ob wir das
wirklich glaubt was er da sagt oder ob
besondere Redaktion ist die ihm gesagt
hat der Fokus was dazu sagen hat ich
danke ihnen Redakteure in Deutschland
sind frei das gilt für jede Redaktion
ich glaube hier am Tisch gibt es keinen
eine andere Meinung ist und unterstellen
sie nicht wir wären irgendwie gelenkt
dass ein Verschwörungstheorie wenn Ihnen
das nicht gefällt was ich gesagt habe es
ist völlig in Ordnung aber es ist meine
Meinung und dann glaube ich auch sie
basiert auf Recherche vielen Dank frau
Peters danke dass Sie so klar ihren
Meinung gesagt haben und heraus etwas
sagen konnte was auch wichtig ist wir
gehen nach Apple haben Martin Bauer ist
am Telefon guten Tag
herr Bauer sie müssten eigentlich
sprechen können
die Leitung ist freigeschaltet
dann springen wir doch nach edersleben
zu Jürgen Fuchs herr Fuchs bitte sie
haben das Wort guten Tag guten Tag an
die Runde
möchte ich formulieren haben wir es
gerade bei den Grünen nicht mit einer
Partei zu tun der mitgliedert oder
Minister in diesem Moment ihre
Entscheidungen
unbeschwerter treffen
hinsichtlich der Konsequenz und Wirkung
und Auswirkung das hat eigentlich damit
zu tun Herr Schönborn wir hatten schon
mal dieses Thema
inwieweit sind denn die Minister in der
Lage fachlich zu entscheiden ich glaube
die einzige die bei den Grünen weiß
worüber sie spricht ist die Frau Lemke
im Bezug auf Umwelt und Naturschutz wenn
ich dann die Äußerungen von der Frau
Döring Eckert Eckert denke verstopfte
Leitungen und und und
mir fehlt so viel bei den Grünen und bis
zuletzt eigentlich deren Ehrlichkeit von
denen man ausging
vom Wirtschaft gab es immer
das ist meine Frage ja vielen Dank darf
ich einmal nachfragen sie haben gesagt
Entscheidungen würden von grünen
Politikern unbeschwerter getroffen
meinen sie damit leichtfertiger
sie haben mir aus dem Mund gesprochen
das stimmt sehr gut weil man das morgens
unterschiedlich verstehen kann mögen sie
ja selbstverständlich ich glaube es gibt
zwei Ebenen dabei das eine ist
wie werden
politische Entscheidungen mit großer
Tragweite
getroffen und wie schnell bin ich dabei
dafür über was anderes vielleicht
hinwegzusehen ich glaube das ist da in
dem Fall passiert im Engagement die
richtigen inhaltlichen Entscheidungen zu
treffen insofern würde ich ihnen zur
Hälfte recht geben
herr Fuchs Grüße nach edersleben ich
probiere noch mal ob er Bauer uns jetzt
hören kann Herr Bauer guten Tag
dann trenne ich die Leitung und wir
gehen in den
Südwesten nach Saarbrücken
guten Tag bitte sehr Herrn schönen Tag
Horn ist mein Name gut an die Runde ich
verfolge fast jeden Sonntag hier den
Button und finde schon interessant aber
weil es wird zu viel diskutiert in
Deutschland diesmal irgendwas bewegt
wird das meine ich jetzt mit dieser
Sendung sondern vor allen Dingen unvers
sogenannten Volksvertreter und
VolksvertreterInnen deren Arbeitgeber
wir sind weil wir sind wählen zum einen
zum zweiten Länder in der Missbrauch wie
eine Vorrednerin schon sagte
dann muss er zurücktreten ist ein
kleines Amtes mehr würdig und auch wegen
der Energie wegen den Wärmepumpen ich
habe immer das Klima lüftungswagen
gearbeitet in den 80ern und das sagt uns
damals schon unser Oberingenieur die
Zukunft ist die Wärmepumpe und Wärme
Rückgewinnung das wurde über Jahrzehnte
in Deutschland verschlafen da hätte ich
gerne von Ihnen dazu eine Meinung von
dem Herrn der links von ihnen sitzt also
von mir aus gesehen rechts vielen Dank
sehr gerne Herr von ich weiß genau wer
sie meinen es ist Albrecht von Luke ja
ich kann Ihnen ja nur zuständig Teile
das ich glaube und das muss man immer
wieder auf den grünen die überhaupt nur
den Anspruch haben jetzt etwas
Grundlegendes zu ändern zugute halten
dass sie mit den enormen Defiziten
Versäumnissen einer eigentlich
30-jährigen nicht ökologischen Politik
ist zu tun haben und das ist der Grund
warum ich sage ja es ist vieles jetzt im
Falle falsch gemacht worden man muss
sich sogar manchmal fragen ob vielleicht
genau das Fachwissen das ist ja das
eigentlich immer keiner würde dann
reichen genau dieses Fachwissen
absprechen genau weil er sich seit 20
Jahren mit dieser Frage Wärmepumpe
beschäftigt hat alles geschrieben hatte
die Konzepte lagen da vielleicht war das
genau der Kardinal Fehler dass deswegen
die sozialen Fragen ein Stück weit
hinten runtergerutschen und diese Frage
der Abwägung die kriegen wir es ist
vertretbar und sozial abgefedert darüber
aber das gerade hier die Sachkompetenz
nicht vorlege gerade im Falle reichen
ist abwegig es ist aber Problem das
natürlich Habeck er ist Politiker durch
und durch eigentlich genau deshalb
diesen Fachmann braucht und so festhält
das ist das Kardinalproblem aber man
muss eben leider sehen Fachwissen und
das wird die Affäre oder der Fall
reichen durchaus auch Fachwissen ist
leider nur das eine die politische
Umsetzung die Kommunikation und vor
allem dann auch eine Regierung die
gemeinsam steht und die nicht dem
anderen Koalitionspartner permanent den
Rücken fällt und letztlich die Grünen
alleine stehen ist das ist das andere
und daran kann diese Koalition und das
ist das Thema ja vielen herzlichen Dank
hatten wir jetzt in zwei anrufen das
Thema nicht also wie viel Fachwissen
braucht man an der Spitze eines
Ministeriums oder wie kombiniert man das
Fachwissen die Expertise mit dem was man
dann auch politisch umsetzt
wir sind in
Ittenbach bei Christoph lösch guten Tag
Herr lösch ich weiß natürlich überhaupt
nicht wo hinten ist aber schade
okay
ich bin im Rheinland etwas nördlicher
orientiert bitte sie sind dran ja ich
fasse versuche mich kurz zu fassen ich
war schon im Hotel Tulpenfeld
Mitglied Gründungsmitglied der Grünen
ich bin als Kölner Baumschützer
begeisterter grüner gewesen hat
Wahlkampf gemacht und komme jetzt zu
meinen Fragen könnte es vielleicht sein
dass die Wählerschaft die ja nicht
grundsätzlich dumm ist deswegen die
Grünen nicht mehr wählt weil man die
Elektroautos weil man Batterien forciert
man weiß ganz genau dass man die
Batterien die man jetzt benutzt nicht
recyceln kann was Lithium alle anderen
und so weiter abbaut abgebaut wird
abgebaut wird von Kindern dass man das
nicht nachliefern kann also die Umwelt
zerstört und warum geht man nicht jetzt
komme ich zu meinem herzpunkt Glauben
sie das auch daran liegen kann dass die
Grünen nicht für die Freiheit von
Journalismus eintreten ich rufe hier aus
Freiheit für Julian Assange tut mir leid
ich muss das machen ich glaube bei all
meinen zahlreichen Gesprächen
unterscheiden sich die Grünen nicht mehr
für einen anderen Parteien genau das
gleiche hatte keine reicht dafür der ist
völlig überfordert der hat seine
Staatssekretäre das ist meine frage ich
glaube es liegt daran dass ich die
Partei für Dinge entschieden hat die
nicht zu verwirklichen sind ohne die
Umwelt zu zerstören danke Herr lösch
danke dass Sie auch Ihren Hintergrund
erläutert haben ja ich schaue mal auf
die beiden Damen Frau Ruß Frau junge
wahrscheinlich mit unterschiedlichen
Positionen darauf
zustimmen kann wo ich damit gehe ist ich
finde es immer schön wenn jemand sagt
dass die Lehrerschaft nicht dumm ist und
dass die durchaus ihre Gründe haben zum
abzustimmen oder so zu denken die sie
eben denken weil es kommt alles
irgendwoher das ist ja nicht so dass
dass die Grünen sich das wünschen können
sie müssen damit leben was was ich eben
anrichten auch in den Vorstellungen und
Meinungen der Menschen
ja ich kann auf jeden Fall noch mal zum
Trost sagen wir hatten gerade Interview
mit Claudia rot Grüne im
Bundeskanzleramt die sich für Assange
eingesetzt hat das jetzt nicht die
Partei aber immerhin sie sind davon
genau Kulturministerin und das zweite
auch da gebe ich Ihnen recht
Umweltschutz und Klimaschutz ist so
widersprüchlich dass es uns alle zu
Verzweiflung bringt und zu
unterschiedlichen Schlüssen und das
schade selbstverständlich die Grünen
weil es keine ideale Lösungen gibt
bedanke mich herrscht wir springen nach
Erfurt dann guten Tag
danke für Ihren Anruf sie sind dran
ich möchte gerne die Frage stellen in
der ganzen Diskussion über Wärmepumpe
und so weiter kommt mir einfach zu kurz
der Start die Gesamtgesellschaft hat die
Aufgabe die
Bedingungen zu schaffen dass eine
wärmewende gelingen kann und wir wissen
alle die wärmewende hängt nicht an der
Wärmepumpe Pumpe allein sondern daran
dass wir von der fossilen Energie
wegkommen
jetzt hat jeder einzelne Besitzer die
Möglichkeit entweder die Heizung neu
einzubauen jetzt oder aber wie es immer
gepriesen wird sich an das Fernwärmenetz
anzuschließen nur es gibt keinen Plan
für den Ausbau der Ferne es gibt auch
weiterhin keine Pläne die einzelne
Ortschaften gesamt versorgt werden
können und damit kann die wärmewende
nicht gelingen wir können nicht
mittendrin anfangen und beim einzelnen
obwohl gesellschaftlich gar nichts geht
wurde das heißt sie meinen die einzelnen
müssen jetzt also Haushalte Bürgerinnen
und Bürger
sozusagen die Last tragen die entstanden
ist weil zu wenig im Hintergrund
passiert
wurde und da ist mir egal welche Partei
an der Macht war sondern es wurde
verpasst und wir der einzelne soll es
jetzt richten über Verbote und das kann
ich nicht nachvollziehen ja sehr teuer
also es ist sie haben natürlich recht
das ist das wenn man nur Handwerk
diskutiert eigentlich wenn man so einen
großen Eingriff macht dann muss man
eigentlich früher hieß das Technikfolgen
Abschätzung das heißt man hat überlegt
ich mache irgendwas ich ändere als
Gesetzgeber und dann gucke ich erstmal
was kann hinterher passieren und das hat
nicht nichts stattgefunden und führt
auch zu dieser vetteraffäre wenn wie die
Zeit geschrieben hat reichen es mit
reichens Reden und Grüne mit grünen
reden dann werde ich nicht mit
gebäudetechnikern Reden die vielleicht
anderer Meinung sind dann werde ich
nicht mit Wirtschaftswissenschaftlern
reden die andere Meinung sind und
vielleicht auch nicht mit
Sozialwissenschaftlern die auf die
sozialen Folgekosten hinweisen wenn man
so tief eingreift dann kann man sich
nicht auf die eigene Partei politische
Blase an verlassen sondern muss das Ding
einfach viel breiter anlegen und
deswegen ist dieser große handwerkliche
Fehler auch so ein Rückschlag für die
Klimapolitik danke nach Erfurt folgen
und wir springen ja es ist ein großer
Moment an diesem Sonntag mittag dass er
von Lucke und Herren sich einig sind im
Norden waren wir noch nicht Margarete
Keller in Bremen wo nächste Woche
gewählt wird hallo willkommen
bitte fangen sie an
also ich bin ganz entsetzt über die
Diskussion bei Ihnen vor allen Dingen
von den beiden von der jungen Dame und
dem Herrn Reiz und die verbreiten zum
Teil ich will nicht gerade sagen lügen
aber Unwahrheiten
das ist jetzt
ja
ich bin so aufgeregt dass man so viel
falsche Sachen hat dass man alles so
falsch interpretiert die ganze
herzkampagne auf die Bild so
einzusteigen gegen die Grünen so zu
wettern das macht mich krank wie dieses
Klima mich krank macht ich verstehe das
nicht ja Frau Keller ich spüre
spüre wie aufgeregt sie sind insofern
danke dass Sie das mit uns geteilt haben
ich bin immer ein bisschen vorsichtig
wenn man ja doch ehrenröhre Vorwürfe
macht und jemand wie Unwahrheit
unterstellt aber ich nehme es einfach
als ihr gesamtes empfinden und insofern
danke dass Sie dabei sind sie haben auch
das Schlusswort gehabt danke mich bei
Ihnen hier im Studio und wünsche Ihnen
einfach einen schönen
sonnigen regnerischen Restsonntag
tschüss
[Musik]
Bulgariens Berge majestätisch
ursprünglich und wild eine Landschaft
mal fruchtbar mal sanft geschwungen mal
karg